I'm not a huge fan of of the
militarization of the police and stuff
but if you have
armed groups
that are causing that kind of chaos and
and Mayhem you're going to have a
serious problem with your Society like
Atlanta is going to have a mess until
those people get clean until they clean
up the situation and that if that means
that you have to start throwing people
in jail you have to because they're
they're ignoring the rights of the other
people in Atlanta the problem isn't oh
you know it's it's it's the problem
isn't that the Atlanta police are are
heavy-handed or whatever the problem is
that there are actual anarchists and
Communists looking to start a revolution
in Atlanta right now and that's there's
no two ways about it if you talk to them
they call themselves revolutionaries if
you talk to them they will say that you
know that they are looking to engage the
cops give them the fight they want